hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
when the chapter 2 of season 2 event
ended named the device we were left so
many questions and only a few days later
the new season began and all those
thoughts fell out of sight out of mind
now we have time to think we're going
back to see every moment agent Jonesy
was watching us in order to piece
together what will happen next
can we uncover Jonesy's plan slap code
atom arrow in the star to support this
kind of content and think about
subscribing let's do this
[Music]
agent John Jones wasn't revealed until
139 weeks after Battle Royale began 973
days after we all started playing this
game mode but the thing is we already
know Jonesy and everything he's been
through and now with thanks to many of
you guys we have four story theories to
unlock the truth The Watcher concept the
matrix enigma the vendor tech conundrum
and the multiverse theory the most
simple explanation to the reveal of John
Jones is explained by the files on his
desk and the actions on his monitor
agent Jonesy is watching us and always
has been
let's take a trip down memory lane to
prove it you ready for some nostalgia
[Music]
[Music]
back on September 20th 2017 way before
we understood the importance of this
game the first character we saw puffed
their glider in close-up was none other
than John Z who went on a shotgun
rampage
but let's not focus on that Jonesy along
with Ramirez was the first skin to have
a variance in the form of the skull
trooper and when 50/50 was revealed
Jonesy was the one who shot first we
could call these coincidences as there
were only eight skins back then but he
continued to pop up season after season
when the meteor crashed landed in season
four Jonesy dressed as a dinosaur was
there who grabbed the first-ever
Infinity Gauntlet Jonesy moving on to
season six who watched Kevin that you
raised the house into the air and didn't
bat an eyelid
Jonesy munching on popcorn Jonesy has
been duplicated and altered many times
over the years but he remained present
throughout everything simply watching us
going back to present day and enjoyed
his office this is all backed up it's as
if he's watching us on a monitor and
collecting the data just like The
Watcher in the Marvel Universe
watching and recording but never
interfering the problem with that theory
is that Jonesy did interfere with the
world which leads us to our second
theory and my personal favorite the
matrix enigma something from the real
world has somehow made it into the
digital world of Fortnight let me
explain
I'm taking great inspiration from the
movie The Matrix for this one if you
haven't seen it
humans plug into the matrix kind of like
a virtual reality with all the physics
of the real world gravity is just how
you expect it to be but by being aware
of the matrixes rules you can bend them
and break them impossible jumps can be
made superhuman reactions are witnessed
regularly in the movie a program becomes
sentient and tries to break out of the
matrix
kinda like Midas did last season but
this rabbit hole goes much deeper so
we've established agent Jonesy is
watching our every move from his lush
office in a video back in 2018 I talked
about the fortnight world being a
simulation a loop in time which we
continued to return to now in 2020 this
is widely accepted as true as canon a
fortnight so how does it tie to the
matrix well here's the first thing the
design of agent Jonesy is highly similar
to that of Agent Smith in the matrix a
man tasked with destroying external
factors in the matrix and look their
offices are quite similar to Agent Smith
just like Jonesy can take the form of
any avatar they choose in the world but
something happened when he faced the
hero of the movie Keanu Reeves hang on
we've got Keanu skins in four nights
already every time Agent Smith
replicated himself just like Jonesy
something was copied over from the real
world and into the simulation program
shared memories were now possible
because of all his meddling as proof for
this we simply need to look at bunker
Jonesy
back when the lava flew and we were
forced to hide in bunkers Jonesy made
the decision to consume pili to survive
but remember how pili was created
another Jonesy clone this was the
catalyst that made the connection
between Jonesy's avatar in-game and the
real john john's outside memories began
to be transferred to bunker Jonesy
during this time locked in the dark
digital world
Jonesy began to see visions and painted
them on the only canvas he had a wall
things he could never retain from a
single loop memories he couldn't explain
and future events that were impossible
to predict
he saw the creation of the mech he Faust
saw the vaults the tapestry he created
here included so much history but also
clues to the future the desert island he
foresaw the season of the flood and even
predicted the flare guns inclusion but
whose memories and whose plans were
these from all this evidence it's clear
to see in-game Jonesy is beginning to
connect with the real man agent Jonesy
John Jones back in his office we could
surmise John Jones is a programmer may
be watching over the world with his
co-workers and his co-workers so
happened to be renegade Spitfire Ramirez
Wildcat Hawk Banshee and head hunter the
original developers all in digital form
as playable characters in the world
along the way other programmers joined
the simulation team and those avatars
were added to the game have we now seen
proof that the program is connected to
fortnight are unaware that this is a
two-way street and every time they log
online the characters in-game are
becoming self-aware
the biggest example of this is probably
- last season let's use him as a test
case following the rupture of the nexus
point and the breaking of the first loop
the new world had us fighting for ego or
altar for ghosts or shadow discontinued
into the next season but midas had far
bigger plans he was somehow aware of the
past and knew his time in this world
would be shocked and ultimately decided
to try to break free again just like
agent smith midas tried to open the
connection to the real world three times
we ventured forward but each time we
were dragged back in the connection
wasn't strong enough and midas was
deleted from existence a glitch in the
program but his actions have lasting
effects we are now all aware of the
outside world and over the next season
we must try and get back their midas his
bond with jewels looks to be the key to
the real world so we'll have to wait and
see but we must remember one thing
our final visit to the real world gave
us the ability to hear but once we were
sucked back into the Fortnight world
those words became gibberish again under
cycle we started wait wait wait
will this be our only chance to save the
world we live in and get the answers we
deserve or we'll each live event tell us
more about the puppet master agent
Jonesy historic theory we've had for
almost two years now and remains an
excellent theory especially after what
happened in Chapter one the doctor
vendor man theory if you played save the
world this is the theory you likely
already know save the world is a story
in which 99% of the world have been
replaced with zombie-like husks hunting
down the last remaining human
strongholds in that story we follow the
work of dr. van der Mann a brilliant
scientist who perished before we ever
met him over months of playing we
finally spoke to him via artificial
intelligence and were told of his plans
to prepare the world for survival then
we heard nothing we waited we waited we
waited some more but dr. Vin de Minh was
no more well that was until the visitor
spoke in Chapter 1 mute is the other the
visitor told us about the loop and lets
us know that we are stuck our memories
wiped from existence the realization
that the visitor and dr. Vin de man have
the same voice is testament to why we
never found out how the doc died and
saved the world it's because he isn't
dead he's stuck in the loop with us all
dr. Vindi Minh is desperately attempting
to free us from this simulation and now
we have witnessed agent John Z we can
see that he is the bad guy here
attempting to keep dr. Vindi Minh locked
away as a rival company takes control in
the real world essentially setting the
agents of ego against vinda tech Jonesy
repeatedly stopped us from breaking the
cycle by increasing his efforts to
distract us with boss fight with
Marauder pods and natural disasters
keeping us all from finding the identity
of the 7 and the importance of penny ok
that last bit is just for me and team
thick but the point still stands
it appears the bunker is the key to this
story theory and there could be a twist
in the tale
if those doors ever
and always remember the ego logo we see
on Jonesy's desk he's simply the bunker
rotated
[Music]
so by now I've given you three potential
theories is any right do you agree with
any well here's one more to consider
before we finish the multiverse
if comic books have taught us anything
it's that there are multiple versions of
the world we live in created with
different eventualities a cosmic
construct they call it of what ifs and
buts for example one world never saw the
creation of Kevin and another world
would see the enforces engulf the island
and in occasional worlds life continued
as normal
there was no storm there were no husks
we had no reason to save the world on
the 4th of November 2018 everything we
thought we knew was smashed when we took
part in the butterfly event for a moment
we transcended our own world and entered
this in-between place of infinite
possibilities this scene was in
reference to the Doctor Strange movie in
which he explores time and space in mere
moments and only the rift butterfly
could return him to his own timeline we
experienced that too and far too quickly
we were brought back home but the
visitor understood and via those rift
beacons began to bend time and space
bringing together multiple timelines we
saw Gotham City
we saw star II Stubbs return we knew
this was a possibility thanks to season
5 and those rift edges which saw
fortnight and to the real world
dragging Viking longboats and other
items through time and back to the
island Midas was somehow able to
remember this and attempted to break the
storm cycle and that led us to jump to
another universe and in this universe
it looks like a Jonesy is trying to find
a way to communicate with us this would
explain why Jonesy was shook off' by our
ability to hear him but it was taken
away from us before we could ask
questions
right I don't want to go too far now we
don't have the answers but each of these
theories are open to so many
possibilities I would love to know your
thoughts and if you think any of these
theories are true if you do let's try
and answer every question we can like
how to save the world tie into this who
are the seven and how are they being
revealed and those enforces I still
don't know why they vanished Thanks to
everyone who offered their theories
which allowed me to make this video
next time we'll break down the narrative
of the island but until then I'll leave
you with one important question is agent
Jonesy Friend or Foe I imagine from
Playstation grenade spin a pleasure I'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]